fans are sounding off after the leaving
Neverland documentary began airing last
night some venting their anger some
defending the King of Pop well tonight
Oprah weighs in on the disturbing
allegations of sexual abuse for me this
moment transcends Michael Jackson it is
much bigger than any one person and it's
like a scored on humanity that is Oprah
with Wade Robson and James safe chunk
the men are featured in the new HBO
documentary leaving Neverland in it they
detail years of sexual abuse
they say they endured at the hands of
Michael Jackson he was one of the
kindest most gentle loving caring people
I knew and he also sexually abused me
for seven years
Oprah's with the men for a special
broadcast after HBO airs part two
can you explain to people why you want
to continue the association if you have
been abused I had no understanding of it
being abuse you know I loved Michael
Twitter erupted last night over part one
of HBO's documentary with many praising
the men for their bravery
Michael's devoted fans however called it
a quote cheap shot since MJ is no longer
here to defend himself
Jackson died in 2009 and during his life
he always denied doing anything
inappropriate with children don't treat
me like a criminal
cuz I am innocent he was there in 2005
during Michael's 14 week child
molestation trial he was acquitted on
all charges and Wade Robson actually
testified on his behalf
did Michael Jackson ever touch you
inappropriately not at all I learned so
much from him as an artist and as a kind
human being Wade now says having a sign
forced him to re-examine his own
childhood meanwhile the Jackson estate
is not backing down in its war against
the HBO documentary it's a one-sided one
point of view documentary the estate
filed a 100 million dollar lawsuit
and the Jackson family attorney took aim
at the docks credibility today on CBS
this morning
you have a situation where these
accusations are made by two people who
have testified differently under oath
last night the Jackson estate released
this to our concert film on YouTube many
say the apparent goal to divert
attention from HBO the family is
expected to drop another concert film
tonight and I just spoke with an opera
scamp and they said that over knew this
was possibly gonna get criticized for
doing this special with people thinking
that she was taking sides but she is not
she just wants to bring the bigger issue
of child abuse to the forefront to be
discussed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]